Hey guys, listen, I wish ivermectin worked
for Kovac.
I wish hydroxychloroquine worked for COVID.
I wish a zee PAC as throw mice and worked
for COVID.
I really do, because these things are cheap
and ubiquitous, but we have to operate in
the real world and no matter what.
Marjorie Taylor Greene or Joe Rogan or anyone
says about a medication.
The way we determine whether a medication
works for COVID is you do a randomized controlled
trial with a placebo arm and then it's peer
reviewed and published.
And then we have data, OK?
It's not.
Some doctor in France gave hydroxy to 30 people.
That's not.
That's not the way we do it.
OK.
We look at peer reviewed our cities.
We now have that for ivermectin.
We have a study just published called Efficacy
of Ivermectin Treatment on Disease Progression
among adults with mild to moderate COVID and
co-morbidities.
We have a study.
Read the study.
It's not super long.
It will tell you everything you need to know
about ivermectin for COVID.
The question that the study asked is does
adding ivermectin to the standard of care?
Because remember, you always want to test
things against the standard of care?
Does adding ivermectin to the standard of
care reduce the risk of severe disease in
patients with COVID and co-morbidities?
Well, the findings in this open label randomized
clinical trial of high risk patients with
COVID in Malaysia, a five day course of oral
ivermectin was administered during the first
week of illness, and it did not reduce the
risk of developing severe disease compared
with the standard of care alone.
This is called This is a science.
This is what we call a science.
Conclusions and relevance in this randomized
clinical trial of high risk patients with
mild to moderate COVID ivermectin treatment
during early illness did not prevent progression
to severe disease.
The study findings do not support the use
of ivermectin for patients with COVID 19.
This is it now would be the responsible time
if you promoted ivermectin to make sure your
followers know it doesn't work because there
are lots of people who only get their medical
advice from people like, you know, Hannity,
Joe Rogan, whoever.
So they should now say, We've been wondering
about ivermectin.
We have a proper peer reviewed our city.
Ivermectin doesn't work.
We tested it.
Now there are some people who will say, you
have David that was only tested on people
over 50 with co-morbidities.
Those are the people at risk.
Like the same people who say, take ivermectin
are the people who say, you don't need to
worry about this.
If you're healthy or young, you just don't.
And that's mostly statistically true.
So why would you want to test ivermectin on
people who don't need to do anything to recover
from COVID with no problem whatsoever?
So we need treatment for the people more likely
to die.
That's why it was tested on these people,
by the way, for things that do work.
It's not just that anything cheap David's
against anything that was mentioned early,
David's against vitamin D.
We've been talking about vitamin D and COVID
for a long time, and it's not clear whether
taking vitamin D is protective or whether
getting COVID lowers your vitamin D. But there
is now a study which says vitamin D levels
appear to be important when it comes to COVID.
A new study that considers pre infection vitamin
D levels confirms their link to severe disease.
We have identified that yes, it's not just
COVID lowers vitamin D if you have a lower
vitamin D level before getting COVID.
Your risk of severe COVID is higher now, the
researchers say.
The findings don't necessarily imply vitamin
D treatment will impact outcomes, but they
suggest maintaining a normal level of vitamin
D.
This is cheap.
This is a great thing, right?
I tested myself for vitamin D right at the
end of winter of 2020, when this was all getting
going because there was the suspicion that
there might be something vitamin D related.
I my vitamin you want a vitamin D level of
30.
I tested myself and I was at.
So from October through April, I supplement
vitamin D a thousand units per day.
I checked with my doctor, my doctor said that
amount is fine.
You're not going to experience vitamin D toxicity.
That's a great thing to do.
It may or may not be protective, but having
a good vitamin D level can't hurt, and it
may be something that is worth doing and it's
really cheap.
The right loves to say no one wants to recommend
cheap stuff like ivermectin that you can do
now.
Vitamin D is cheap, and it sounds like it's
worth doing.
Of course, talk to your doctor before starting
it.
There might be something about your situation
where your doctor would say, Don't supplement
vitamin D, but vitamin D is really cheap,
and it is now being looked at more and more
strongly.
So what I want is to do things that are shown
to work, and that's the most important thing.
Ivermectin study doesn't work for COVID.
Anybody who promoted it should make sure their
followers know we have a study and it doesn't
work.
Don't seek out ivermectin for COVID.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show we'll
take a very quick break.